We need an expression here in order to subset our
data frame. So really I'll just run the subset command
on our pf data frame or pseudo-Facebook users and I'll
take ages that are less than 70. Now the question
said 70 or less so I should really use less
than or equals here. Running this code we get a
very different summary statistic. In fact, this tells a different
story about a negative relationship between age and friend count.
As age increases, we can see that friend count
decreases. It's important to note that one variable doesn't
cause the other. For example, it'd be unwise to
say that growing old means that you have fewer
internet friends. We'd really need to have data from
experimental research and make use of inferential statistics. Rather
than descriptive statistics to address causality. You may have
noticed that I left off the method parameter from cor.test.
And that's because cor.test defaults to using the Pearson
Product-Moment Correlation. No matter what we do. Adding this
in as a parameter, we should get the same
result. And running this code, sure enough, I do.